we have over the last few years
established a set of standards for what
we call college success and the way we
develop those standards is we took the
AAU which are as as you know our our
research at colleges and universities we
took those standards that they spent
four years developing and use those as
our and those were standards set for
what does a kid need to know our student
need to know to go to college and
succeed and we took those from the 12th
grade and took them down to the 6th
grade in math and English in which we
said if this is what you need to know at
the end what do you need to know after
the sixth grade seventh and took it all
the way up and we've we've built not
only have we built the standards but we
also have the programs the curriculum
that allows kids to take what what would
prepare them for those year-to-year
standards and we call that program
springboard and and that program we've
spent the last three or four years
developing and it it also feeds very
much into the AP program which as you
know is a college-level course taught in
high school is we have 37 of those
courses they are recognized by colleges
and university across the country and
you're given credit for taking those
high school courses based upon their
graded and 125 and if you have a 345 you
get credit in college so we've really
developed those those standards looking
at what the AAU standards were and what
we believe a student needs to know to be
successful to go to college I think
standards is really a belief in in
people believe it believe that all of us
have a lot much more capacity and
capability than we know and it takes a
good teacher to bring that out I think
it takes a good leader to bring that out